scrolling through all the options on
Netflix may end up taking up your whole
night so we're here to help you narrow
it down if you're looking to park it on
the couch and dive into a heart-pounding
thriller here are some hidden gems worth
checking out cheap thrills a bloody
pervy thrill ride cheap thrills follows
a rider / auto mechanic named Craig
who's fired from his job on the same day
he gets an eviction notice depressed
Greg winds up in a bar where he catches
the attention of a sociopathic couple
with too much time and money on their
hands
Jeffrey Fellowship does a shot first
gets 50 bucks boom the couple offers
cash - Craig and his friend they carry
out a series of escalating deaths each a
little worse than the one before the
tension ratchets up with each challenge
until it's horrific final shot an image
that'll leave you wondering what would
you do for the right amount of money the
two faces of January said in 1960s
Greece the two faces of January follows
a wealthy American couple played by
Viggo Mortensen and Kirsten Dunst they
run across a shady yet charming grifter
played by Oscar Isaac who makes his
living swindling tourists soon enough
the trio is covering up a crime and
running from the [ __ ] if you're in the
mood for something simmering and
suspenseful complete with an exotic
locale and plenty of pretty faces hiding
all sorts of dirty secrets then check
out this Hitchcockian film the Stanford
Prison Experiment inspired by the most
infamous study in the history of
psychology the Stanford Prison
Experiment we'll leave you battered
bruised and gasping for breath the film
follows a group of college students
selected to take part in the scariest
role-playing exercise of all time half
are assigned to the part of prisoners
and the others are given guard duty from
this point forward you should never
refer to this as a study or an
experiment again it's a grueling
experience made all the more intense by
its talented young stars if it weren't
based on a true story this would feel
like a horror movie instead it's a
gritty reflection of the abuse of power
in our world which is far more
terrifying
the trust and the underrated Thrilla the
trust Nicolas Cage and Elijah Wood play
cops who are sick of their lives and
hoping to turn things around by cracking
a massive safe owned by criminals hidden
inside a grocery store the Joe quickly
assembles a plan to pull off the heist
but while the first half of the film
goes by fast the second half slows down
as they put their plan into action and
it's here that the trust truly shines
throw in a killer ending and you've got
a bizarre little thriller that totally
deserves your attention I don't feel at
home in this world any more critically
speaking I don't feel at home in this
world anymore was a smash hit winning
the grand jury award at the Sundance
Film Festival still this wildly
entertaining film hasn't gotten enough
mainstream love and it definitely
deserves a bigger fan base the story
follows an increasingly frustrated nurse
named Ruth played by melanie lynskey
yippin in my yard I have not your dog
every day Ruth notices that people are
just awful unwilling to take it anymore
Ruth joins up with her antisocial
neighbor played by Elijah Wood to bring
the crooks to justice Wood is hilarious
as a wannabe tough guy and Lenski might
be the most relatable protagonist in
cinematic history all this frustrated
nurse wants is for people to stop being
jerks and if you don't shape up she's
gonna track you down and teach you some
manners Willman shot almost exclusively
inside a nondescript BMW Willman is a
claustrophobic thriller a movie that
makes you feel just as trapped and
helpless as its hero played by Frank
Grillo the film follows a nameless
getaway driver who sucked into a game of
cat and mouse
he begins juggling phone calls as he
works his way up and down city streets
trying to discover who's pulling the
strings all while keeping his teenage
daughter out of harm's way
the tension slowly ratchets up to Grillo
who attempts to puzzle his way out of a
job gone wrong Grillo is at the top of
his game here and if this were a just
and fair world his performance in real
man would turn this guy into an a-list
star mother equal parts social satire
slapstick comedy and dark mystery mother
follows an unnamed herb
who's determined to prove her mentally
handicapped son is innocent after he's
arrested for a brutal crime that's
easier said than done as nobody believes
a story but as she digs deeper into the
case
she's inevitably forced to make a
decision that proves there's nothing
more powerful than a mother's love
snowpiercer director bong joon-ho is
such a skilled filmmaker
that you'll be sitting on the edge of
your seat and no matter how many
suspense flicks you've seen before you
won't be able to guess where this film
is headed thanks for watching click the
lure icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to
[Music]